seti the first was the father of our
friend ramses the great
just like his son he was a hugely
successful pharaoh
but in father-son rivalry there's one
category where he wins
hands down his mummy because
seti the first boasts some of the finest
mummification work in
all of ancient egyptian history
mummification is an incredible process
of drying out and embalming the body to
preserve it
ready for its journey to immortality in
the afterlife
key to it all was the preparation of the
body
[Music]
typically your brain is pulled out
through your nostrils with an iron hook
next all of your major organs are
removed apart from the heart
ancient egyptians believe this was the
center of your being
these organs are then preserved in
special jars
so they can be reunited with their owner
in the afterlife
[Music]
your body is then covered in assault
called natron and
left to dry for up to 40 days
finally the now mummified body is
wrapped head to foot
in hundreds of meters of linen bandages
attached with a glue
and magical spells are cast to protect
the mummy
and prepare it for safe arrival in the
afterlife
but set his mummy is unusual
his face is incredibly well preserved
he looks almost perfect not what you
might expect
from a body over 3 000 years old
but frankly seti's had quite a lot of
work done
unlocking the secrets behind seti's
youthful good looks
is professor of radiology sahar salam
i always looked at his mummy and i said
this is not mine
this is a sleeping beauty and i've
always wondered what was his secret
the secrets revealed to me
that the ancient egyptians
were very efficient
as plastic surgeons so was it really
plastic surgery
yeah and they actually placed fillers
around the nose and the mouth in this
region in the
cheeks and even in the temporal what
does this tell you about their ideas of
ancient beauty
for men as well as women the ancient
egyptian would
like to look like his gods
there is something very very charismatic
about him he was the
most well mummified person
from ancient egypt that i've ever looked
at i love the way
you talk about him i bet you wish you'd
met him definitely
we we will meet one day in the afterlife
it's brilliant brilliant well good luck
egyptians beautified set his mummy to
make sure it was in the best possible
shape
to travel to the afterlife once there
seti would need a stunning home for all
eternity
[Music]
you